así es son 84 los observadores
internacionales entre misiones oficiales
y también visitantes de diferentes
países de américa latina y el caribe
ellos han tenido un proceso en días
previos han tenido sesiones académicas
conversatorios con los aspirantes
presidenciales han tenido por supuesto
sesiones con expertos del tribunal
supremo de elecciones para conocer la
parte técnica la logística hicieron
recorridos previos y el día de hoy
tienen que estar en diferentes rutas de
observación establecidas para los
diferentes grupos en todo el país a esos
84 observadores se les suma también 17
personas de la organización de estados
américanos y también otras 17 de la
embajada de eeuu en costa rica todos
ellos están distribuidos para observar
cuál es la forma en que se desarrollan
los comicios aquí en costa rica y
posteriormente tienen que rendir un
informe sobre lo que ocurrió en la
votación